Họng người chính dựng em 200, 2 năm 2020, không cạnh sát giờ thông,
có quan tình quân ái thì diện tiền báo phản ái nguy phạm của người dân đối với xeu tổ khách
năm 2018, nhà CTH. Đăng đưa thông từ vũn có tốt đàn án,
còn ái đi quốc lộ 200 bắt, nằm có hình vì thị phạm chở quà số người vi định.
Đến khoảng 20 mốt dựng bú mì phút thường ái, tổ không thác lựng em sát xeu tông đường bụng
bụng số 2, cuối vực bà đã dự, kiểm tra, kiểm soát xe khách nói chiếc tại quốc lộ 200,
tự, kiểm soát đặc dự, kiểm soát đặc dự, kiểm soát đặc dự, kiểm soát
xe khách nói chiếc phạm các lối, trở quà số người vi định,
sau mấy mốt trên 2020, chế không đúng tính đường để chiến bệnh tại đuếp hoạt động,
li và đường có biển bó hợp cộng đường với loại trên tệ đuệnh.
Tổ không thác đoệnh bệnh bản vi phạm chiến đuổi lại xeu tây,
xin năm 2020, chúng ta mới bệnh chú sát các băng, tình xe lai,
và chuyện phung tịt không tin ở hát xe đuổi tây, tổ mức phạt tiền,
hát xe lai xe, phản năm 2020, chế mấy trăm niên đầu,
chương mươi đến dễ phép lai xe, chú phung tịt phạt 1 năm 2020.
Hành vi trở quà số người tìm ở nguyên cơm mất an toàn xe ao thông,
hành được chứng tếm đến tính mạc, giúp hành khách bản người thân xe ao thông.